you know oh my gosh our local parish
water
welcome to shinjang this is where a
technological police state is being
pioneered where kindergardens are
fortified our United Nations experts say
around a million people are being held
in detention centers China says their
training facilities designed to
eradicate extremism we came here with
questions to find missing children the
more time we spend here the stranger and
more unsettling things became
our story started several months earlier
here in Istanbul some wiggers have made
it out of China many have come here is 3
years old she is never met her brothers
or sisters
the mother Kavanagh is a Weger XL she
enjoyed years of repression in Xinjiang
when she became pregnant with Mercier
she decided to flee so that her daughter
would be born outside China
she came here at 3 years ago her husband
was meant to follow with her other
children but he was arrested and
sentenced to 10 years in prison for
visiting a foreign country and for
terrorism she had no contact with her
family all that time in one day last
December she finally saw a glimpse of
the daughter she'd been separated from
on Chinese social media not at home with
her family apparently in a state-run
institution this is old
you can feel guilty Columbus responded
19 those who escaped shinjang have lived
a long silence cut off from their
families they thought their children
were safe with relatives at least but
several we guys told us they believe
that when their family members were sent
to detention centers their children were
put into state-run orphanages and
so-called kindergartens
abdul rahman's wife and mother-in-law
returned to shinjang in August 2016 he
stayed in Turkey to work they went with
his daughter and his son his son is
answering in Mandarin rather than the
Weger language his family speaks London
using hardship neither chanclas ji kept
occupied Twinkie business it's risky for
the wiggers who fled to try and contact
their families both for them and for
those they've left behind still at the
mercy of the Chinese state but at a loss
Calvin or and Abdul Rahman both asked me
to look for their children they cannot
travel back to China for fear of being
detained a we could and so we went into
the heart of sea in general
as soon as we are out at the airport we
are followed by at least four cars
somewhere there number place covered it
was the same on 3rd plain clothes police
keeping tabs on us whenever we tried to
slip away shinjang is a digital
surveillance state with cameras
everywhere
knives are registered to a persons
national identity number and must be
kept tied down there are security checks
everywhere at petrol stations there
shopping centers traditional Islamic
customs have been discouraged or banned
this sign forbids women to wear veils
than men to grow beards and previously
busy mosques have gone quiet
we sought no worshipers here nor heard
any calls to prayer even on a Friday and
these are any the visible signs of an
intense crackdown by Chinese authorities
Sudan is China's frontier an autonomous
region six times the size of the UK more
than half is 24 million inhabitants come
from Muslim ethnic minority groups most
of those are we girls and they've long
had a difficult relationship with the
Chinese state over the last 15 years in
particular there have been deadly
protests riots and terrorism so this was
the Chinese Communist Party's response
starting in 2017 the first reports of a
network of detention centers began to
emerge huge facilities all across
shinjang were around a million we girls
have been sent for re-education US
officials have called them concentration
camps the few images that have emerged
are deeply disturbing this footage shot
by a drone shows around 600 prisoners
kneeling their head shaven their hands
bound blindfolded a European security
source told Sky News that these images
from Xinjiang are believed to be genuine
for a long time China denied the
detention centers even existed then they
began a propaganda push the censors did
exist but they were not detention camps
they said the official name was a
vocational training centers where we
guys could learn the language
[Music]
nor China although this was necessary
official said to eradicate terrorism and
extremism China is happy to show the
world what it wants to be seen it
doesn't like the world looking for
itself we started looking for are you
sure here in return a city of around
300,000 people in southwestern China her
mother Kelvin or had been told Aisha was
in this so-called kindergarten or he can
be sure if she is still even in the same
city we'd come up with a list of 14
possible kindergardens where we thought
she could be one by one we went through
them many of the buildings look normal
but others have barbed wire fortified
entrances along with the ever-present
CCTV cameras and armed guards police
followed us all the time
anyone we spoke to even just asking
directions was questioned afterwards
everyone told us they had never seen
Aisha the last kindergarten so children
were usually collected at 6:30 so we
decided to wait and see if anyone came
no parents did but we weren't expecting
this a truck and three diggers
dispatched the kindergarten for sudden
emergency roadworks and their quality
it's broken they're just gonna dig there
we came back at the next day no sign of
any roadworks
he's running as we got closer a digger
came racing up the road it was a bizarre
display straight out of The Truman Show
so here we are and as we got a bit
closer to this digger which was scooping
earth dumping it there rather bizarrely
the driver exited the cabin at quite
some speed we don't know where he's gone
and you can see it is an impressive show
it's a ridiculous show because we're not
trying to find state secrets here we're
just trying to find a bit of information
about the children's of Xinjiang the
Chinese state simply makes it impossible
to find answers here and it goes to
extraordinary lengths to do so but
official statistics tell a story and
what's happened to Shin Jang's children
in one region Kashgar the number of
children in official orphanages has
massively increased at the same time as
crackdowns
in 2014 around 5,300 children were held
in orphanages that number dropped off
until 2017 when it suddenly spiked to
more than 7,000 and the number of
children in kindergarten has also
increased this data from eight regions
shows that around 650,000 children
registered for preschool in 2015 last
year there are more than 1.3 million the
figures include young children who live
at home receiving normal schooling but
government documents themselves appear
to show that children are taken into
care when their parents are sent to
re-education camps the camps are still
cloaked in secrecy but we wanted to see
them ourselves and this is where things
got more and more surreal authorities
were ready for us at every turn one camp
was down this road unfortunately was
blocked because of her to prepare work
on a gas line we were told they took an
idiosyncratic approach to fixing it the
next day we came back this time there
had apparently been so I tried to walk
around it I was told that wouldn't be
possible I asked why they said there was
no why it kept happening here we
approached a different camp
another camp another traffic accident
this one with a less than convincing
limp
it didn't seem too serious but the road
was nonetheless closed then armed police
arrived and they made us leave but we
didn't give up
this time under cover of darkness to
give our minders the slip we're going
back to a place where we think there's a
camp they told us there's an accident
the other day so go back very early on a
Sunday morning to see the same sort of
thing happens for the first time in a
week it looked like we weren't being
followed and so on the edge of the city
it emerged from the gloom a huge center
with high walls watchtowers and
spotlights on full blaze satellite
images show its full extent this area
appears to be the detention center with
high walls and watchtowers the complex
on the left is apparently the
re-education facility the security is
less strict the buildings more like
dormitories this sign reads aim to mean
the stability and security of society
inside here according to reports
hundreds of people are taught about the
Communist Party's achievements and made
to write self criticisms a program of
the Doctrine ation
we left Houghton and traveled north to
Axew city close to China's border with
Kyrgyzstan this is where Abdul Rahman is
from and we hoped to find his son but
here we had less information to go on
just a home address
we didn't even get that everything this
is the house it doesn't look very open
but we'll give it a go now our mind has
changed tactics if we stopped filming
and went with them the official said
they could offer us something better a
chance to speak to a graduate of one of
the centers everything had been set up
ready and waiting for us
the officials kept a close eye
throughout even as they tried to keep
out of shot this man gave us as Chinese
not weakening I need your son he told us
he attended the centre last year yes in
Cambodia gamble Tongass for what's in
japan centerpieces coma or Felicia I go
in sepia tagalog hi Virginian so far so
good
the station master John told me a feeder
granted a hard-on for a young doctor
yonder Medusa stretchy muscle per song I
was Duda what relationship relations
work which occurred now has a good - oh
yeah under the goddess is a leader in
truth this felt about as real as all the
traffic accidents and roadworks we'd
seen
the other side of the story can only be
glimpsed these weaker men in buses
without number plates skipping traffic
lights with a police escort it's
impossible to say whether they're
prisoners detainees or something else to
report and shinjang is to see through a
glass darkly - no only in part but in
Turkey
those have been inside camps and made it
out give alternative accounts the
difference is night and day
goober ha Jalil is a weaker woman from
Kazakhstan she told us she was detained
in China on a business trip and kept in
a vocational training center for 15
months
- mr. Machado drop to mr. Tom vegetable
samosa turn the key yen ask Shannon
Whisnant shelled Rebecca sugar killer
occupation ocean worsened icky tap water
Mina dr. Hannah body
the governor the governor Kim Jang told
us that the sentence were like boarding
schools is that accurate sir
marecus man yeah no come it'll be
research on December 2nd and I can
second chance reintroduce telling
throughout our reporting we've asked the
Chinese authorities for access to the
camps we asked them for a comment on
this report we awesome for information
about goober haja alleles detention we
asked them for any information they
could give us about the children of
Kelvin or and Abdul Rahman they did not
respond for those who have escaped it is
still the silence that is hardest to
bear
I guess you put it ma nizzle up Cartman
and possibly any teacher from you
mending medication alignment in Kearney
Tim you master item boom Sharad
Bominable personal matter